no man's sky is coming to Xbox game pass
in June the next state of play is going
to focus on less of us part two and
could even more big games come to switch
I'm Cassidy and this is your save state
for Tuesday May 26 first up no man skies
coming to Xbox game pass and the Windows
PC store in June it's the first June
game announced four-game pass but
there's no exact release date yet it
will also come to the Windows PC Store
but no date has been confirmed there
either the game was already available on
Steam and developer holo games has more
ambitious expansions and updates planned
for 2020 so look out for those if you're
like me you're probably wondering could
more big games get ported to switch one
dev definitely think so the XCOM 2
collection Borderlands legendary
collection and Bioshock the collection
are all coming to switch this Friday May
29th vertuous is the studio that ported
XCOM 2 and Bioshock and they're also
working on the outer world switchboard
virtue a senior producer Zhang Chen Wei
believes any current gen game can be
ported to switch talking to Nintendo
Life Chen Wei said quote off the back of
our work on StarLink battle for Atlas
Dark Souls remastered the outer worlds
and the coming XCOM 2 we now have no
doubt that switch adaptations can be
worked for games on any of the current
generation of consoles and that
statement checks out which also has
witcher 3 and Wolfenstein 2 ports and
doom eternal and burnout paradise
remastered will be released in the
future all I want is to be able to play
persona 5 royal on switch what games do
you want ported to switch Sony's next
state of play will focus on the last of
us part two and it's happening very soon
tomorrow in fact the next state of play
airs Wednesday May 27th at 1 p.m.
Pacific and 4 p.m. Eastern director Neil
druckmann will narrate the stream diving
deep into gameplay mechanics the stream
is expected to be about 20 minutes long
and there will be about 8 minutes of
gameplay in a brand new area the full
game is out on June 19th and for all
your duel fans voice actor Troy Baker
will be joining us for our play for all
charity event which is happening soon
play for all kicks off on June 1st
it's a multi week event that is going to
be the best place for you to get all
your latest gaming news features
interviews and live streams also we're
partnering with Direct Relief to help
raise funds for healthcare workers who
are risking their lives daily on Kovan
19 relief efforts play for all we'll
have over 100 hours of awesome content
and will feature the GameSpot team as
well as our friends from across the
industry like the Giant Bomb crew Alana
Pierce no clips Danny oh do IR voice
actors from some
of your favorite games and more for the
ever-expanding list go to GameSpot so be
sure to join us starting next week to
celebrate gaming and raise money for a
great cause and that's your safe save
for Tuesday
I'm chastity and can find me on GameSpot
universe or on Twitter a chastity
underscore V and for all your latest
news stick with GameSpot
[Music]
[Music]